applications okay thank you everyone
thanks Balaji I'm very happy to be here
my name is hi Tom I'm from the
University of Illinois and today I'm
going to be talking about sparse Fourier
transform algorithms for real-time
applications and so this talk is a bit
heavy on signal processing so I try to
keep it at a very high level but at the
very least you need to know what the
Fourier transform is and so what the
Fourier transform does it takes a signal
in time and computes its frequency
representation so it extracts the
frequency components it is almost used
everywhere it's used in audio and video
processing it's using GPS and radar
medical imaging then a sequencing even
gas and all its exploration and many
many more applications and that's why if
we can improve the way we compute the
Fourier transform we can benefit a lot
of applications and domains so how do we
compute the Fourier transform in 1965
Cooley and tahqiq came up with this
great algorithm called the fast Fourier
transform the FFT and for FFT for signal
of lengths and samples it computes the
Fourier transform in n log n time so
it's almost nearly linear and at the
time it was a huge improvement it made a
lot of applications practical but fifty
years later the FFT is no longer fast
enough in some applications like GPS it
consumes too much power in other
applications like medical imaging just
collecting all the samples to compute
the FFT means that the patient has spent
a long time in an MRI machine in other
applications like Radio Astronomy where
they built a square kilometer array on
Australia and South Africa the amount of
data that comes in per second
they can't even store it forget about
computing it so the natural question
that comes up is can we compute the
Fourier transform faster than FFT and
then sub linear time
and the idea to do this is to leverage
sparsity let me tell you what we mean by
that it is often that the output of a
Fourier transform is very sparse which
means that most of the signals are
negligible and there's only few spikes
that have all the energy and this is
exactly the property which is going to
leverage to compute the Fourier
transform faster than FFT and at the
high level the intuition is very simple
there's no point going and spending time
to compute signals that are just
negligible or noise all we have to do is
find these Peaks and compute their
values and you might wonders like how
often does this sparsity appear in
practice and actually all the
applications that I just mentioned are
actually sparse in frequency domain GPS
medical imaging video and audio data or
radio astronomy seismic data genomics
you name it that's why there was a lot
of interest since 1992 to work on faster
algorithms to compute the Fourier
transform the best algorithm was
basically the fastest run time was due
to Gilbert muta Krishnan and Strauss in
2005 and what they showed is for a
signal of length n if it is K sparse
what that means is that there is K large
coefficients you can compute these
coefficients in K log n to the 4 and
this would improve over FFT for any K
that smaller than n over log n cubed in
2012 together with Piatra and Akina
kitabi and Eric price we have shown
algorithms that can actually compute the
Fourier transform for sparse signal for
the exactly K sparse case when there is
no noise you can do it in K log N and
you can show that this algorithm is
optimal assuming that FFT is optimal and
when you have noise for the
approximately K sparse case you can do
it in K log n log n over K and this is
log n factor away from the lower bound
and it would improve over FFT
for any k that's small often you know by
motion okay
so perhaps what's important about these
algorithms is they turned out to be very
practical and we managed to show their
impact on the many applications so we
were able to customize them and use them
in wireless networks GPS medical imaging
computational photography circuits
biochemistry and astronomy
now since this workshop was an oral real
time decision making I'm going to focus
on real time applications and
specifically I'm going to focus on
wireless networks and I'm going to talk
about two main applications of Fourier
transform
the first is spectrum sensing and
acquisition and the next is millimeter
wave 5g networks so let us start with
the first one since 2013 for the past
five years FCC have been telling us that
we have been having a spectrum crisis
all the spectrum has been allocated and
there's no more spectrum to use and if
you're a person who works on wireless or
radio frequencies you'll find that
that's surprising
because if you go and look at the
spectrum you'll find that most of it is
unused so this is a figure from the
Microsoft spectrum Observatory that's
measuring the spectrum over a period of
one day between one gigahertz and six
gigahertz and as you can see between 3 &
6 we barely see any signals what does
that mean is FCC wrong well it there's
many different entities but the idea is
that although the spectrum has been
allocated so FCC have sold it to
different parties it's not being used
efficiently so most of the time there
are many bands in different areas so
this isn't Seattle if you go to another
area this situation might look different
but there are many frequency bands that
are not being used
and so how the question is how can we
use it more efficiently and we know the
answer the answer is something called
dynamic spectrum access and what this
means is different radios and your cell
phones or different devices what they're
gonna do is they're gonna sense search
for unused frequencies and then go and
use them but to be able to do that
efficiently and in dynamic fashion what
needs to happen is that the radio needs
to be able to capture gigahertz of
spectrum in real time so I need to be
able to sense what's going on and then
find the unused bands and in real time
switch there and use it so basically the
division is this basically came from the
white house time for Bama is that there
can create these spectrum highways right
so the FCC has to open it first right
but basically the motivation is that
there's a lot of data that shows it's
not being used and so why not open it
for sharing but we if you want to share
it you need to be able to sense it in
real time it turns out that real-time
gigahertz spectrum sensing is actually
quite difficult what you can do today is
actually just scan tens of megahertz at
a time so you sense tens of megahertz
and a new scan and the problem with this
is that not only it takes time you can
miss fleeting signals and signals that
are not always there so why is it
difficult one of the key challenges is
something called high speed ABCs and
what an ADC is is an analog to digital
converter it takes the analog signal it
samples it and digitizes it if we were
to look at the ADCs that are being used
today on cell phones and radios there
are mostly tens of megahertz so they
test sample ten of mega samples per
second they're very low power they have
high bit resolution so they give you
like twelve to sixteen
bit per sample and they're really cheap
but if you want a Giga sample per second
ADC it's going to consume way more power
it's going to have way less bit
resolution four to six Atmos and it's
going to be quite expensive
so the question is can we sense the
entire spectrum without sampling at
eager sample per second
the idea is in the spirit of this talk
to use sparsity if the spectrum is
sparse
we know from sparse recovery theory that
you do not need to sample it as fast as
a Nyquist rate so you not do not need to
sample as twice the highest frequency
and indeed there's been a lot of work on
using compressive sensing to solve this
problem the main issue however is that
compressive sensing and even our initial
sparse Fourier transform algorithm
required random sampling it's very hard
to build a random sampler in hardware
now there are ways around it but turns
out that they still you have to still
use multipliers that multiply at Giga
sample per second that consume a lot of
power and even if you can do that just
recovering the spectrum is
computationally very intensive
so what we need to do is we need to have
a sparse Fourier transform algorithm
that doesn't require complete random
sampling so we can implement it with low
speed analog to digital converters and
it needs to be a sub linear recovery
algorithm so we can compute very large
FFTs in real time
so how does this sparse Fourier
transform works so say this is your
input time signal and let's say this
spectrum is extremely sparse it just
have three peaks so the way it works at
a very high level is in two steps
bucket eyes and estimate in the first
step we're going to divide this spectrum
into buckets such that the value we get
for each bucket is the sum of frequency
coefficients within that bucket
if we can do that most of the buckets
are going to be empty so we can
immediately ignore all the frequencies
in them we don't need to go and run more
computations on those and for the
buckets that are not empty we need to
estimate so out of all the frequency
coefficients that mapped into that
bucket which one is the large one
so how do we bucket eyes and estimate
cheaply so you have a very wide spectrum
but you can build low-pass filters or
bandpass filters potentially right so
this this is one way to bucket eyes is
like by bandpass where that's not what
we're gonna use actually in a second
because that to build such a thing you
would require kind of to sample at the
highest sampling rate so we cannot
bucket eyes this way it just for
illustration it's easier to see this
form of bucket ization so how are we
gonna really bucket eyes so if you know
signal processing you know that if you
sub sample a signal in time below the
Nyquist sampling rate what you get in
frequency is aliasing of the spectrum
what does this mean let's take an
example let's say this is your time
signal and this is its frequency
spectrum if you subsample this take
every other sample and then taken a 50
of half the size the spectrum is going
to fold on itself so basically every two
frequencies are going to sum up together
and really this is a form of pocket
ization where frequencies every to sum
up in one bucket
and turns out this is a very easy and
cheap way to bucket eyes all you have to
do you can subsample using a low speed
ADC and then take it much smaller FFT
so now let's take a toy example let's so
let's say this is the spectrum and it
has only four frequencies and we
subsample it we take every other sample
so it's gonna arias and then they're
going to sum up together in buckets most
of the buckets will be empty and we can
ignore them and there are two other
types of buckets ones that have
collisions and ones that have just a
single isolated frequency that map to
that bucket so let us for now focus on
the isolated frequencies we can find
their value from the value of the bucket
but what we don't know is out of the
frequency that mapped into that bucket
which one is the red one so to do that
to figure out we're going to leverage a
property of Fourier transform which says
that a shift in time creates a phase
rotation in frequency what does that
mean if we cannot repeat the same
process with a shifted version of the
signal by a time shift of tau the phase
of that signal is going to change by two
pi F tau where F is the frequency that
we're looking for so we know tau because
we can pick it we can measure the change
in phase and from it estimate the
frequency F
good but what about buckets that have
collision the phase is not gonna depend
on either so to solve these what we're
gonna do is we're gonna bucket eyes
again but we're gonna use a property of
co-prime subsampling so we're gonna sub
sample again at a rate that's co-prime
with a sub sampling rate we use the
first time and this core prime property
is going to ensure that if two
frequencies collide in the first bucket
ization they're not going to collide in
the second so if we take this example
and we bucket eyes again with this
co-prime sub sampling rate we are
guaranteed that the green and blue are
not going to collide again in the second
one and now all we have to do is iterate
between the two we estimate the
frequencies that are isolated and then
we go and subtract them once we subtract
them more frequencies we'll get isolated
we can estimate them subtract them and
we can keep going back and forth until
we found all the frequencies
yes yes so basically if a frequency is
isolated between the bucket ization and
the shifted bucket ization the
magnitudes of that frequencies remain
constant right
only the phase change yes well as if
there's a collision both magnitude and
phase change so what can we show about
this so we can show for the exactly
sparse case but only when the
frequencies are randomly chosen we can
show that the algorithm will take order
K samples and will run in K log n
computations for the approximately k
sparse case the algorithm will take K
log n samples and will run in K log
squared n computation it's good to note
here that basically power and cannoned
here at Berkley independently reach the
same result around the same time they
just use the coding Theory approach to
solve the problem yes
the same about that corresponding to
having been equally spaced Americans
is it bad thing
so so basically the the randomness yeah
so basically he's saying where does this
why do we need it to be random so we
need it to be random is because our
algorithm is not randomizing things so
that's why we can prove an average case
analysis of the problem we cannot prove
it in the worst case because basically
we are limited by how many co-prime sub
samplings we can do right so other
versions of the algorithm where we can
take random samples we can have worst
case guarantee so we don't care where
the case parts what's the distribution
they come from but in this case because
we're limited by how many co-prime
sampling we can get right we have to
have an assumption on this parsecity so
that's that's exactly true so what he's
saying is yeah but in practice it's not
random right and indeed you can use that
if you feed that as a prior that you
know that if a frequency is there then
there's a band that FCC set that you can
know that the entire band is there and
of course you can use that in practice
to really improve the algorithm so you
cluster frequencies together sorry based
on what FCC allocated okay so now with
that we can actually build a gigahertz
receiver because we sub sample the data
uniformly so we can use a bunch of low
speed ABCs and we have a fast algorithm
which won't compute a lot of power and
so we went ahead and we used
software-defined radios to build a
receiver that can capture almost a
gigahertz of spectrum right in real-time
we using a bunch of low speed ABCs with
an accumulated digital bandwidth of 150
megahertz so six times less and
basically what we've shown is that
roughly up to 5% it works really well so
I'm not going to go into the empirical
results so we
move on but they're in the paper so at
this stage someone should stop me and
say look the entire goal of what you're
doing is to make the spectrum get used
efficiently right and if the spectrum is
being used efficiently then it's not
going to be sparse so we kind of went
back and defeated the entire purpose so
what are we going to do what if the
spectrum is not sparse is there anything
we can do or are we just doomed we have
to use like high speed ABCs
it turns out we're not and because if
the spectrum is not sparse we can take
the signal and actually make it sports
let me tell you what we mean by that so
let us say this is a non sparse spectrum
that is being used efficiently what
we're gonna do before sampling or
anything we're gonna pass it through a
hardware filter that looks like a comb
so basically it kind of sub-samples
these frequencies so this is a filter in
hardware and once it's subsamples these
frequencies you get a very sparse
spectrum and you can pass this sparse
spectrum too sparse Fourier transform
algorithm so you can now subsample at
very low rates and solve the problem now
of course you're not recovering the
entire signal but what you're recovering
is the occupancy so you're covering the
occupancy of each of these bands and
that's the goal so we now no longer can
recover the entire signal so you cannot
decode for example but what you can do
is sense which bands are being used and
which are not and actually building such
a thing turned out to be very very hard
and only until recently like colleague
of mine used MEMS acoustic resonators to
build these highly tuneable cone filters
and we showed that actually now you can
build such things and then pass it
through and then the problem becomes
actually simple even when the spectrum
is not sports
sorry what's the tunings that you need
basically we tune how far these are
apart right and basically how much loss
you get sample yeah so basically this
will be set mostly will be set by how
probably the FCC allocates the band's
right so if the bands are very small if
I divide my bandwidth into one megahertz
Trunks then probably I need one
megahertz if I divide it into ten
megahertz trunks then probably I need
one every ten megahertz
okay
so with this with this parts Fourier
transform we've shown how we can capture
and sense gigahertz of spectrum in real
time now let's move to the second
problem which is millimeter wave
networks you do know the occupancy and
you would say frequency as you said you
don't know you can't recover the signal
in that frequency you cannot recover so
you're not transmitting yet right so
your own your sensing to discover which
are occupied now the truth of the matter
is that like let's say the algorithm
decided that this band is occupied you
can actually go and sense it exactly
with like a narrowband filter right and
detect make sure that you're ready like
the e result is correct the other thing
is that I don't wanna go in details but
there is some confidence metrics that
when you recover some frequencies how
well your confidence that this is
correct
that you can extract from the algorithm
original goal was applying spectral
views yes
so you discover that this is an
underused part of the spectrum and you
decide to use it you still have to
recover that signals so basically once
you discover its unused right you can
kind of just so basically this is going
to be a separate circuit for just
sensing that you do it continuously
right and then you'll have your
traditional like low tens of megahertz
kind of band that you can use so
basically the only difference now is you
add basically part of the circuit that's
dedicated for sensing is discovering the
bands and then you chew on your center
frequency to what it is so this there's
this is a good question it's like I'm
sensing how does my receiver know where
I am right so there needs to be some
coordination right and like if we just
basically both should be sensing and
there's team to be so basically for the
purposes of this we're not looking at
the protocol of how we coordinate to
make sure we're on the same channel but
you're right
okay so let's move to millimeter wave
and basically if we look at the wireless
spectrum between zero and hundred
gigahertz for the last X number of years
we've actually been operating here below
six gigahertz that's why the spectrum
ran out and there is plenty of spectrums
tons of gigahertz of spectrum that is
not being used and recently the FCC you
realized that and started to open more
and more spectrum some of it for
licensed use for cellular some of it for
unlicensed use and right now you have
almost more than 14 gigahertz around 60
of unlicensed spectrum that anyone can
use for free and this is more than
everything we've ever dreamed of there's
lots of applications so these are called
millimeter wave bands and there are lots
of applications the main one is for 5g
cellular network access and backhaul but
there are other applications and virtual
reality wireless data centers and
connected vehicles with their reach
exactly so nothing is for free right we
get tons of bandwidth but the signal
attenuates really fast so the range is
very limited and what you need to do to
compensate for that is today you have
one antenna on your receiver or
transmitter but with millimeter wave you
have to have an antenna array and that
allows you to focus the direction of
communication so you focus all your
power in one direction to compensate for
their loss and the good news is because
the frequency is so high the wavelength
is so small that we can build very large
antenna arrays so we can put hundreds to
thousands of antenna elements on the
back of your phone
and basically extend the range very wide
and get a very narrow beam the problem
with this is that it really changes the
way wireless networks operate so today
all wireless networks cellular and Wi-Fi
are what we call broadcast so when you
transmit the signal goes in all
direction in the truth of the matter
that's a blessing because no matter
where you are you're going to receive
the signal and even if you move you're
still gonna receive the signal but if
you go to millimeter wave and you're
using these very narrow beams basically
unless the beams are aligned sometimes
you can't even know that there is an
access point so basically communication
at very high data rates is only going to
be possible when the two beams are
aligned and even worse if you just move
a bit the connection drops and you have
to realign again so how can we align
well the naive way is to do an
exhaustive search so if you have n
directions that you can beam in right
you can try for every direction at the
access point or that the client you try
all possible directions at the access
point
so the problem with this is that it so
it takes order n-squared measurements
and here a measurement is actually you
send a data packet small one and you
measure the value of the channel and so
this is even for small arrays it's
prohibitively expensive like no one even
thinks of implementing this so when the
people who do the standard started so
they decided that this is way too much
so we're gonna do something something
similar simpler so the standard four
millimeter wave is something called A to
Z dot eleven ad and the idea they came
up with is we're gonna do it in two
stages the first stage the access point
is going to have a very narrow beam and
the client is going to switch to what
they call it quasi omnidirectional beam
so it's almost omnidirectional and then
the AP is going to scan the client will
then discover the best direction from
the AP and then in the second stage
we're gonna reverse the roles they P has
a quasi omnidirectional and the client
is very directional and then the client
is gonna scan and then we're going to
pick the best direction from both sides
and the issue with this is that we're
still scanning so for n direction we
still need to send n packets right and
what people have shown that this is
still too slow and if you want to
accommodate mobility you need to be able
to do it much faster yeah
here I go with I leave the way you are
yeah so I need to know the direction of
your signal because sometimes in kind of
non line-of-sight the direct path is
blocked so you need to kind of they use
a reflection to communicate yeah but
basically yeah because it's very easy to
get blocked because it's narrow and it
ends in you it's quickly but basically
it's you're right and it's kind of the
same problem is we want to discover the
direction the signal can come from right
and so the question we're going to ask
is how can we find the right alignment
in sublinear number of measurements and
without having to go and scan and try
all possible directions so before I tell
you I need to tell you a bit how the
millimeter wave radio kind of creates
these beams so what happens is there's
an antenna array right and then each
antenna is connected to what we call a
phase shifter so it just modifies the
phase of the signal on each antenna
before they sum up and by setting these
phases you kind of create this
directional beam and by changing them
you can steer it in any direction now if
we look at the antenna array Theory the
math tells us that the signal on each
antenna is actually nothing but an
inverse Fourier transform matrix
multiplied by the vector X where X
represent the directions where the
signal can come from so if X is a vector
the turf sends the different directions
F is the inverse Fourier matrix then the
signal on each antenna is just F times X
and then what you can control is how you
set these phase shifters their values so
every phase shifter adds the face so
it's of the form e to the J Phi so what
we're doing here we're taking the
signals multiplying them with e to the J
Phi summing them this is one measurement
so we can represent it as a vector a of
the phase shifts x FX if we take a lot
of measurements we get a matrix a that's
mixing F X
and again there's been a lot of
measurement work in millimeter-wave and
all this work both indoors and outdoors
led to the conclusion that actually the
vector X is very sparse and the reason
is that the signal takes only few paths
between transmitter and receivers
because at millimeter wave frequencies
there is much less scattering so it's
mostly reflections so there's only few
paths from any transmitter to receiver
mostly three for maximum even indoors so
basically the vector X is sparse and now
we don't have much constraints we can
set a the way we like and so we can use
compressive sensing or sparse Fourier
transform to solve the problem there's
no naive question so basically there is
some packet that has a header right that
tells you the access point ID right IP
address or MAC address right so that you
can tell that this is an access point so
basically it's all in the higher layer
protocols on how to kinda sense this
edge solve this addressing problem so
basically there are a lot of
off-the-shelf right there is even access
points the only issue that I see is that
the hardware design is pretty bad so you
don't get very narrow beams and there's
lots of like what we call side lobe
leakages that kind of really makes the
beam not very narrow but basically in
people are it's still in academia stage
but people have built very large arrays
like you see at people at UCSD build a
256 array this has very narrow beams but
the stuff you find like on commercial
devices has very low number of antennas
and basically it has very wide beams yes
still
comparable to no it's more basically
because you have to you have very large
bandwidth you sample at very high data
rates and so basically that's why you
need mostly you have one receiver you
cannot put a receiver on every antenna
for example it's way too much okay so
basically this is sparse this is a
standard sparse recovery problem but
turns out it's not as simple so it turns
out there's a catch here and the catch
is there's something in RF called
carrier frequency offset and for the
purposes of this talk you don't really
need to know what that is
but what you need to know is actually it
creates kind of a phase that corrupts
the phase of the signal that we're
measuring and this phase changes very
quickly with time so every time we send
a packet it adds a random phase to it
and it's very hard to track and estimate
so basically what ends up happening is
that the phase of these measurements end
up being useless and what we need to do
is take the magnitude to eliminate this
component so what this becomes is a
well-known problem called sparse phase
retrieval problem so how are we going to
solve it
let me give you a very high-level what's
the intuition
so what we're let's say this is the
access point and it's at sixty degrees
relative to the client what we're gonna
do is construct what we like to call a
multi-armed beams and what this means is
like a beam that have directions arms in
different directions if you use that to
capture the signal then you can know you
get some signal and you can know that
potentially the directions are 0 60 90
or 120 and if you repeat this a few
times with different multi arm beams now
you know it's 40 60 100 or 150 so you
can combine this to figure out that oh
it's 60 degrees that's the right
direction so you have a 2d array and you
have a 3d beam forming so you basically
have what we call azmuth and elevation
of planes so you can steer it this way
right yeah yeah
of course it depends how you build your
hardware but assuming you put a phase
shifter on every antenna then you can
steer in 3d okay
so two questions we need to answer how
the hell do we generate these multi art
beams and what is the best choice of
these multi on beams so let's first
start with the first one if we look at
this problem if we look at the vector a
to create a beam that is traditional and
very directional we can actually pick a
as to be any row of the Fourier matrix
so if you pick a to be any row this is
how the beam will look like you change
the row you get a different beam what we
want is something like this so what
we're gonna do is divide the vector a
into multiple segments and then choose
these different segments from different
rows of the Fourier matrix and by
changing which rows we can randomize
which directions the beam has
so this is the first the second question
is how do we pick these beams and what's
the best choice and here we have to be a
bit careful because with the reflections
especially if you have metal reflectors
and you use a beam the signal can
combine destructively to attenuate
itself so you can miss some of the
signals if you're not careful so what
you need to do to solve this problem is
basically have some randomization so
what we need to do is pick these
multi-armed beams to create sorts of
random hash functions so where if we
kind of look at the different directions
each set of directions map to one bin
so if we use random hashing then all we
have to do is use a voting based process
to figure out which directions the
signal comes from of course there's a
lot of more details because actually the
beams are not that discreet and you
cannot separate them that easily but
I'll leave that for the paper so what
can we show what we can show is if you
have ends yeah so basically everything I
have this car discussed assumes that the
client is kind of omnidirectional there
is an extension that I'll just I it's
not part of the talk but basically
you'll incur a K squared here instead of
K if you were to do it from both sides
at the same time right so there is
issues with these kind of creating
omnidirectional beams at millimeter wave
it's actually very hard then they look
very happy sorry for the word right so
so that's why I it's better to avoid
them but it actually makes the protocol
simpler for sure yeah so what we can
show is that you can do it in K log n
where K is the number of paths between
transmitter and receiver and
is the total number of directions so
what we did to test this we build a
millimeter wave radio with phased arrays
and of course I'm not going to go into
the interest of time because we're out
I'm not going to go into the details but
what we can show is you can really
quickly align the beam in less than one
millisecond even through simulations if
you go to each 256 and ten array so you
can possibly get 256 directions you can
get something that's hundred times
faster than what the standard does today
and almost 10,000 times faster than
exhaustive search so to conclude so I
talked about two applications of course
there's way more applications of sparse
Fourier transform but I focused on
spectrum sensing and showed how to
capture gigahertz of spectrum in real
time and millimeter wave networks and
show how to align the beam so that you
can have a continuous communication
really fast so thank you very much and I
will take questions you already asked a
bunch of questions but maybe time for
you can you can create the beam to send
it to multiple devices indeed yeah so
basically the process is that so the way
the protocols are set right is that
there is a learning stage it's called
beam training like where you can quickly
discover the directions to different
devices you want to communicate with and
then there is a data transmission phase
right and the goal is to kind of mana
Mize the overhead of the learning stage
as much as possible and do it quickly so
that as the guy moves you continue it
doesn't change the beam doesn't change
now the good news is that because the
data rates are so high the packets can
be small so we can actually send quite a
few before the beam changes if you could
localize your position yeah so it in in
line-of-sight it kind of helps a lot
because then I know in non line of sight
it doesn't because I still need to know
the paths
[Music]
[Applause]